foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
the last few months have been kind of a
blur filled with moments I sometimes
film but also sometimes don't
and per usual I now have a mountain of
Patchwork footage spanning months and
months of filming and traveling to sort
through and it's kind of overwhelming
it's a whole thing sitting down to edit
old footage and trying to remember what
kind of headspace I was in or why I
filmed one thing but not the other
if I were to try and describe it
imagine you have four or one thousand
piece puzzles and you dump all four
boxes onto the floor and mix everything
together
and then you have to somehow create
something from all that chaos
[Music]
as of this recording I'm currently
camped in the middle of nowhere on day
four of a kind of self-imposed isolation
sometimes that's the only way for me to
get real work done so here we are
hopefully it all goes well and I can put
a dent in all this footage and start
fresh with a new approach and some kind
of plan to post more often because I
really want to
but to be totally honest I have yet to
figure that plan out
kind of just like everything else in my
life right now
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
box for the first time since last
November this is a toilet sent all the
way from Germany according to the
measurements it's slightly large like it
won't fit so my thought is I'm just
going to have to trim these pieces off
and try to rebuild something but
try it out I'm really hoping it's not
too tall because that'll really be a
problem
wow it's in there perfectly
oh you guys it fits perfectly wow this
is gonna be a game changer
and this new issue of Backpacker
magazine just came out and and the
photos in it
it's always really cool to see your own
work in print
[Music]
and you see
foreign
[Music]
so about this wild idea
he's actually a photographer I've long
admired and have always wanted to meet
both him and his dog Maddie
I've been inspired by Theron's
photography for years
from when he was living on the road full
time to his shift into buying land and
building beautiful spaces so when he
offered to let me have the main house at
his Montana Airbnb all to myself for
nearly a week I was like are you kidding
me
foreign
because at that time I was really in
need of a Slowdown
some real quality do nothing Max relax
take a bath dance in the kitchen kind of
down time
and let me tell you this property was a
dream
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh and
[Music]
come along
[Music]
hey
[Music]
go
so baby come down with me tonight
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
two
two down
then we let it go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
so if you run away
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
just lay it on down
[Music]
[Applause]
in front of your eyes
[Music]
then you'd take it back
stay
two to fight that down
then we let it go
[Music]
cameras
let's keep going okay there you go
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
whenever I'm lucky enough to be in the
company of other creatives
I'm reminded of why I do what I do
it's the endless possibilities and the
freedom to dream
to go wherever we want to go and for
however long with no aim other than to
experience and create
but like most things in life that
freedom comes at a cost
there are times when I feel like I'm all
alone aimless and adrift
not only as a Solo Traveler but also
just as a self-employed creative
I don't have an office to frequent with
familiar faces or after work happy hours
down the street or even a boss to tell
me how I'm doing or if my work is
improving
okay honestly I don't miss having a boss
at all but the point is every day is in
a way a guessing game
something I've grown to both love and
hate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where we're going
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
the thought of putting down Roots feels
a little like giving up my freedom
the freedom to be anywhere at any time
and to meet my friends wherever they
happen to be
and other times living on the road feels
like I'm robbing myself of stability and
true community
and the chance to build something I'm
really proud of
it's an internal battle that rages
pretty often if I'm being honest
and I know I'm not alone and feeling
that way
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
I think that's why so many Road lifers
end up laying down roots in a way that
allows for both
our rig for extended travel and a place
to call home
what a spot
I wish my van could get down here
I don't know
I could try
I mean that's what I'm out here working
toward
most days anyway
[Music]
and other days
I just let it all sink in
and do my best to appreciate whatever
beautiful moment I happen to find myself
in
[Music]
numbers
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign